hello my name is Bobby Lee and you're
listening to tiger belly this is our
first episode and this is my co-host and
she is my co-host and also my my lover
and we also have an engineer he doesn't
want to use his real name so we're just
gonna comes gonna make up something
right now you're gonna be brown skin for
skin for skin yeah for skin g-force why
okay he's the only Filipino who you're
not circumcised at all what does that
actually mean though circumcision is
removal of the foreskin if I don't know
what it really means I never really Oh
circumcision I mean for a lot of people
it was in the Philippines people get we
call it Dooley
yeah Dooley is if you don't get to it
you're basically humiliated made to feel
humiliated let me ask you this I
sometimes watch porn and some of the
guys have the penis where they have the
turtle head that sticks a little bit
what's that it's a sweater
what is that call more skin I don't want
it you don't have it I know but I don't
ever want that I know but when you let
me know if it starts doing that because
I will get an operation oh speaking of
which speaking of a lot of foreskin
there's this guy in Mexico who has a
nineteen point five inch penis and so
he's approached the Guinness World
Records or cuz he's like really poor
unemployed he's 52 and so he's like
receiving like government aid because
basically like he's rendered he's
rendered useless because his dick is
just so big right but so he has a
nineteen point five inch penis mhm
but then the circumference of his head
alone is 10 inches it's like a beer can
okay so um kalila said that to me a
couple of days ago but this man and I
looked up online and there's no photos
of his penis online image I don't I
don't want to see an x-ray okay that
could be anything that could be yeah
because that could be like Wolverines
x-ray and in in the first x-men movie
you could obviously see it's like a
human yeah it could be anybody though I
don't know if it's this guy I would this
guy come out with this story he's like a
sad man who can't even have sex because
I don't feel bad for him because let me
tell you this mine is virtually a [ __ ]
right and it's like you know it's not
fair right right so it's like he's
crying that he has the greatest thing on
earth
no because it's soft at 19.5 well that's
his problem
like imagine if it was actually - like
if blood were to actually like flow into
it how much bigger it would get it
doesn't flow I'm not sure I don't think
so but I would I would assume he would
probably pass out if he had an erection
because they all that shunting of that
blood in one area of your body would
cause like some type of like low blood
pressure elsewhere probably pass out so
let's say if he was a dwarf yeah I mean
at that big of a penis yeah you probably
died like all the blood from his body
would probably go under those pns and
that he would die from starvation no
blood I mean if that's how you like to
you know well think of things another
doctor why would ya about doctor i
neither am i we would have to ask you
know that guy's doctor so okay cool so
he's gonna get a reduction no so that's
what I was saying like the foreskin so
the doctor there's a doctor who was like
Oh most of it is just foreskin let's
just lop it off yeah anyways um I wanted
to let you guys know that this is
actually our fourth attempt at the first
episode yeah I kind of want to start
over already
I literally want to start over already
I'm gonna keep going I'm gonna keep
going yeah but I just like I just don't
like the way it began with a 19-point
yeah I just don't you can't open up like
a brand new podcast with it that a
Mexican man's penis okay look this is
okay I'll tell you why this is our
fourth attempt at our first I like the
first one the very first one no we were
talking [ __ ] about everybody else what I
like that's why was this popular it was
you for a whole hour interrogating me
about my ex-boyfriend yes
and it's a people what a years and then
we re-recorded it and we were like we're
not gonna bring up two ex-boyfriends and
then you did the exact same thing I
might go again right now can you not I'm
not going to but I want to I have a
desire to I I'm led the only reason you
can't because remember that one of those
guys really want
me dead okay so it's my my blood in your
hands okay well I'm not gonna do if you
say his name huh can I call him what
I've been calling him what have you been
calling Australian bein can I just say
that that's what he looks like he looks
like Bane without the mask his body is
like huge and bulbous he crushed the
Dark Knight's back you know with his
knee yeah he looks ferocious yeah and
then the other guy I'm gonna name his
name but he's a soccer player a very
handsome professional soccer player and
yet you have to understand Gilbert Brown
skin for skin for skin I apologize when
you use a real name but it's out there
now so Gilbert Brown skin for skin yeah
that this guy I'm intimidated because
I'm if you say if people know me they
seen my body and my body is absolutely
disgusting
it's theirs you don't even know where my
shoulder and my stomach began they just
blend together like you can't name parts
of my body is that part of his body or
his neck torso or a kneecap exactly yeah
I just have this I'm just a yellow mass
of flesh and I feel bad you know and
then and then like I look at your
boyfriend's and they're all like
athletes and athletic and they probably
have big penises like the Mexican guy
and I just feel very threatened by it
that's all that's why I bring it up I'm
threatened I've been with you for two
years now otherwise you you won you've
been winning whoa okay dude I mean I
never I was never even exclusive with
those guys I know it was just for fun
okay no yeah yeah so you got that out of
your way the good-looking guys I got out
this is real and you know real life I'd
have told you this before I'd like to
think I like to think that I have an
avant-garde taste in men I'm very
experimental so I go through phases so
in high school I dated cholos you know I
mean and I went through I took a white
boy to prom and then I just kept dating
white boys through college my last my
guy after that was black and then I went
for the Spanish and then I moved over to
you know the Lebanese and then now I'm
you know in trying out the Koreans
little Korean people little
little Korean people that's good I don't
think that's a bad thing I like to taste
the rainbow okay that's good that's a
good thing opportunity employer
so the other night something happened I
didn't tell you about it but I'm gonna
tell you now and I feel really bad about
it and I wanted to know if it's the
right way to handle the situation so uh
I get off stage I'm at the Comedy Store
it's Saturday night I think was Sunday
and I I had a pretty good set and this
this Russian lady comes up to me and she
goes oh my god I don't know how to do
another Russian accent oh my god no she
just basically said I think you've
larious try to thank you and she goes I
want you to do right for me I go right
what she goes I have a youtube channel
I go oh oh and she goes I go how many
followers do you have
I have 2,200 followers right which is in
the scheme of things not that much right
no not enough to approach a comedian
who's doing a set at the Comedy Store
and ask them to write so then I said to
her I go I'm sorry but that's just not
what I do I don't first of all I have my
own YouTube channel how many followers
do I have yeah I already were right for
that you don't even write for yourself I
know you're right for myself let alone
in Psych so I was trying to explain that
to her and I felt like she was being
offended like why won't you write for me
you know is there a language barrier
like she didn't speak English I know
she's oh no she just had an accent and
it was just like one of those things
where I felt like she walked away
offended and I felt really bad about it
like I can't explain to you that I like
I don't I don't explain her as I listen
lady I make good money doing stand-up on
the road you know I mean I've been on TV
shows before I've made money off of that
and a couple of movies I don't write for
YouTube channels but you can't say it
that way right so you kinda have to go
listen I just that's not something that
I do and she was actually like visibly
you know resentful at me but but here's
your thing you always personalize
everything because I generally think
you're a good guy like if someone asked
for
with you you never say no no I don't and
when someone asks you like basically a
stranger could come up to you and be
like hey dude like I'm hungry can I have
80 bucks and you give it like you don't
even know that [ __ ] person yeah I've
done it yeah I think you're extra polite
to people that that you're actually why
was she mad she was mad at the end but
why do you even care do you know what I
mean like most people would say no and
then never even remember that incident
yeah it's been haunting me for two days
like I did what's the right way to do it
you know maybe it's just in her culture
to just give you stink-eye
do you know what I mean I think is a
cultural Russian thing yeah maybe it's
that whole like you know you know Putin
influence you know they just give you
that rageful I yeah brown skin juicy
Eastern Promises it was a movie with
vehicle murders Morrison the guy that
did he's great he's a great actor yeah
but it's about the Russian mob isn't a
foreskin and there's a scene in it he
doesn't know I don't think there's a
scene in it where he just [ __ ] somebody
up with a knife in a spa yeah so when
I'm in a spa can I go to spas a lot
right and I see a Russian guy and I
always leave do you think that they're
just gonna be like they're gonna stab me
get in a knife fight with nothing a
little knife and just stab me on the
side or whatever what a nice pic yeah I
was just really nervous about Russian
people in general I guess what I think
that there's no laws there was something
like I just get but that's just like the
Philippines like you know over here
everybody if you want to kill somebody
you know you you buy a gun you shoot
them up that it seems to be the American
trend right but in the Philippines I'm
gonna use my cousin as an example let's
not use my my murderous uncle as an
example because we already did that
before but in the Philippines I'm not
even kidding you it's not uncommon for
people to get into a disagreement pick
up an ice pick and just start getting
into a knife fight so that's why I don't
want to ever want to go there and you're
like let's go every year and it's like I
don't wanna get ice picked but then you
know it was funny about this though is
that they both got arrested but they
were both had to be taken to the
hospital but in the provincial hospital
they were taken to the they put both of
their beds together so they woke up next
to each other with like stab wounds
okay we can't talk about your uncle
we've talked about my uncle we could
bring it up again because that was you
know uncle her uncle brown skin for skin
ok brown I can't do both I got its got
it let's condense we got to condense I
can't [ __ ] do it okay
no brown brown skin yeah Brock is brown
okay
you look very brown to me you're welcome
so basically kalila is uncle Saud his
other brother in half with we have to
hack him kill them with a machete
there's one thing if you use a machete
and there's another if you use a saw
alright okay he my bad so yeah he
murdered his own brother because his
brother kicked him out of a house no
Bobby guy you make him sound so awful
he's my favorite uncle just have a
little bit of decency yeah do you not I
mean
alright so what did he love him what are
you doing real quick so you know the
uncle that got killed yeah okay so that
the murderous uncle what's his name are
we allowed to say it to my uncle Carlo
yeah
Carlo yeah my so much Carlo I'm good I'm
we just say this to and when cuz when we
were in the Philippines kalila was in
the hospital and her uncle Carlo was
there right and I'm scared because I
know about that he killed somebody so I
was really scared like I was shaking
visibly shaking and he walks up to me
I'm like oh my god here it goes anyone
he says to me take good care I go excuse
me yeah that's what he sounded like I go
excuse me it'll I go I think he just
said take good care of kalila and when
he said that I imagined him slicing me
and a half with machete you know scary
you know he said in Bisaya afterwards
after he met you what'd he say he said
inside he said you know let him know
that I know I've been in prison for 15
years but I'm still not afraid to scalp
a man did he really say the word of God
he said that you swear to God is that
that
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] but I mean I mean
that is [ __ ] [ __ ]
now let me just look let me just say
this real quick though okay now when I
see him I'm gonna be more scared because
I love my scalp no because I've had my
scalp for like you know for a very long
time and I enjoy it yeah I put like
shampoo on it yeah and I wash it out you
know I mean I sometimes massage it I
love it
you know I'm cool one go you definitely
want it forever
yeah I want my scalp forever right in
fact I'm going to say this I want every
one of my body parts with me till the
end of time till I die like that my toe
fungus on your feet let's not talk about
that by the way about my left foot has
athlete's foot okay so don't even look
at it
I mean brown skin it's bad it's bad I
have bad after school as a matter of
fact you might have to take a break
halfway through this just for him to see
ya scratch it and also on top of it Ed
Asner talked about my foot in a Santa
Monica newspaper you know ed Asner's
he's the old man from up yeah he's a
legend he's also [ __ ] crazy as [ __ ]
we had dinner with him once I loved him
he was like a mean grandpa yeah but he
still talks about my foot yeah he loved
it he hates me oh no because he he went
on a Tom Green show and Bobby was
wearing I'm sandals and then I was like
why the [ __ ] would you show up to any
like professional setting looking like
that and Bobby's like oh I have to air
out my foot because I have fungus and
then he visibly scooted a rope away from
me in fact if you ever want to see that
apparently it's the most awkward thing
because there was a weird energy that
day and him and I were just very
combative and here's another thing
that's [ __ ] I love that Asner but I'm
gonna say this is I did a [ __ ] pilot
with him three years before that I did a
pilot with him and Tom Arnold about us
three working at a hardware store
I'm not lying where I played him and I
those storylines were hit at an asthma
and I would go out and do cocaine at
night you know man I mean it was like a
edgy three-camera sitcoms
yeah but they never picked it up but it
was a multicam show with yet well it
with me Tom Arnold and Eadie as no
answer at his dad and we ran a hardware
store I swear to God
so then I go hey man it's good to see
you again and he goes who are you and I
go I did a pilot with you he goes I
don't remember you I was the third
[ __ ] lead anyway so talk about I'll
tell you why his memory is still solid
why he remembered your athlete's foot he
did and he wrote that article a year
after he met your athlete's foot yeah so
you may not remember everything about
you but he remembers the pertinent
details oh yeah
so anyway talk about your uncle why did
he kill backtrack five topics ago it's
okay go ahead tell everyone
um so my Carlo my murderous uncle he had
he has five children at when all of this
went down all of his kids at this point
were under the age of 12 and the one of
the younger ones has cerebral palsy or
like to a degree and she also is Bush
has cerebral palsy so they live in a
squatter area in the Philippines house
is right and the splutter areas like a
really really poor area to begin with so
basically one day my other uncle who got
killed went into his home and he was
like I sold this home because it was
under their mother's name but he got
somehow like did some side [ __ ] to where
he was able to sell the home and profit
from it and he was like you and your
family are on your own and my uncle was
like he basically understood that as
you're killing me like you've you're
murdering me because you have no regard
for what happens to my children myself
my wife I'm an electrician I make [ __ ]
in like an equivalent of like two
dollars a day you're leaving me out in
the middle of a rainstorm and so my
uncle took that as you're not my brother
anymore and you don't have any love for
me you don't care what happens to my
family and he went crazy and he took a
machete and he killed me on there you
know he stabbed my uncle from the back
and broad daylight and he like severed
his spinal cord and everything huh so
I'm not
yeah I'm just yeah I'm just I know I
[ __ ] sound crazy but I love him
that's fine I love my other uncle too
but guess what and guess what I'm gonna
tell you this and this is a truth right
Jeffrey Dahmer's father loved Jeffrey in
fact he visited Jeffrey all the time in
prison okay
and when Jeffrey Dahmer's father says I
love my son I [ __ ] believe him right
but it's crazy do you know why he's the
uncle I love the most out of all my
uncle's when I was swimming in the
Philippines and that's basically all my
sister and I did we would swim twice a
day train twice a day he was the only
guy who ever showed like an earnest
interest in me and my sister's life yeah
like he he was he almost was like a
second father he's my sister's Godfather
mm-hmm and so my mom we really entrusted
this man to you know to be like a good
man like keep my mom my mom would leave
my sister and I with him all the time
and he was just a really nice person my
other uncles were a little bit more like
aloof you know didn't really we didn't
really like bond that way but my uncle
wouldn't have money oftentimes but he
would he would same thing happened no
we're good it would be stopped it just
stopped right can you see what the last
thing he said was like go so you know
this guy or my uncle you know I just
remember him as somebody who I had great
memories with like there he was just a
kind and generous man my whole life and
that's the only perception that I had of
him and that's the only perception I
will continue to have of him because
when that whole thing in the Philippines
happened I wasn't present for it I was
already in the United States do you
understand what I'm saying
hmm and even from prison he would write
us letters and he was just I don't know
I I feel conflicted about it because I
just you know obviously he murdered he
murders his own brother my cousin
Jennifer I told you that my cousin
Jennifer I have on my mom's side of the
family that's what all the crazies are
and she's great Jennifer's great but she
she was in Bulgaria and
she was dead in Bulgarian guy and it was
a husband actually they were married and
they were at a Chinese restaurant in
Bulgaria and the waitress didn't bring
like some sort of sauce that my cousin
asked for so she tackled her to the
ground and she stuck her heel in the
woman's eye high-heeled a high-heeled
into the woman's I were a gouged her out
so then this Bulgarian guy had to
smuggle her out of the country because
she was gonna get arrested for attempted
murder or whatever so and I still love
Jennifer so I get it yeah so your family
members that do crazy things but you
have a different relationship with them
I mean obviously I mean I like richard
kuklinski richard kuklinski the ice man
who worked for the mob he was a murderer
yeah the Ice Man right they did a movie
about him was it called Chronicles and
anyway I'm sure I'm sure there's one of
his kids loved them still no but that's
how he was talking on on the documentary
he you know he's a cold-blooded killer
like he doesn't he's he's a psychopath
right and one of the the hallmark traits
of a psychopath is you they don't show
remorse and he says he doesn't feel
remorse you know towards any of the
crimes that he committed but the only
moment yeah that he gets emotional is
when he talks about his daughter yeah
where's kids yeah or his kids and family
and it's crazy to think that this is the
same guy who would what do you do tie
two cats tails together you know and
throw them over a clothesline they call
it Harry Caray so they what is he Harry
Caray I can't even like fathom that the
I can't because I automatically think
about our own cats you know they used to
back in the back back in the days to tie
two cats tails together and throw them
over a clothesline and they would rip
each other apart oh my god that's awful
yeah but this is that guy what's his
name fluke Lenski yeah richard kuklinski
he was just um you know he was Moody
yeah yeah yeah as bad days yeah yeah
anyway um you know your uncle fine I
mean if I go to the Philippines I'll
I'll just I'll go I'll get over it you
just have to win him over Bobby I don't
[ __ ] believe that I even have to do
that I think you should just buy him
like a couple packs of dried mango I
Sokolove rise I'm gonna do that yeah and
just say hey choke Carlo like Carlo yeah
maybe I'll get him a really nice like
gold-plated machete engraved yeah you
know and it would his brother's name
like r.i.p alright be on it or maybe
like little lines I could do in prison
of how many like how many times he's
killed somebody with that I should be
more sensitive about this topic because
my mom was really devastated when this
happened because basically she lost two
brothers and also a month after that
whole thing went down
my mom's mother their their mother died
I think from heartache so I should be
more sensitive I shouldn't laugh out
loud like I just did three seconds ago
you know I I encountered a lot of
violence in my lifetime my father was an
alcoholic and he was very a rageful
alcoholic and he was extremely violent
he used to beat the [ __ ] out of me and
my brother all the time chases down the
hallways when he got drunk and stuff and
at a family family gathering once he
took a butter knife because his sister
my aunt was drunk and she said that how
come you didn't marry somebody prettier
than my mom and my mom was right there
so my dad took a butter and I jumped
across the table and stabbed her in the
neck she didn't die but she was got a
little wound and you know and I still
love my dad but it's still like behavior
that's still not right and shocking I
saw my dad do a lot of [ __ ] like that
you know okay so I have a question then
because you did an Asian thing no but my
question is obviously in this day and
age if something like that were to
happen I would if let's say for instance
you were in an abusive relationship and
you were a friend of mine I would be
like yo you know like that absolutely
leave that guy and get a divorce but
back in the day people just worked
through near homicides like when I talk
to your mom now it's just like yeah I
lost a couple
teeth you know what I mean like I I
feared for my life my mom's missing
teeth because my dad used to punch it
out now in nowadays if that happened the
woman would leave but well you would
make him leave
I would hope she would yes she would
hope but then if you look at his parents
now the mom takes care of his dad 24
hours a day you know he's had a stroke
so he's he's bound to a wheelchair and
she would never leave his side and it's
I can't even say that's like Stockholm
Syndrome because she's like no like he's
done some [ __ ] up [ __ ] but then you
just work through near homicides yeah
but it's so I would never because I was
trying to trace back how I became a
comedian and it was I think because of
he was so violent and I didn't know how
to survive that that I just kind of
turned everything into it like a fantasy
joke so I mean I would act out in school
and I would just be just I used comedy
and humor as a defense mechanism you
know and so I was wondering like nobody
in my family does comedy why would I
what would drive me to do this awful
career or like comedy which is a [ __ ]
difficult thing to do it's just like to
move up in the comedy club system is so
emotionally and spiritually grueling you
know and it's like but it's I think it's
my dad that did it you know yeah I think
it's definitely like a coping mechanism
like that's the only how do you cope as
a child like what do you do like you got
into drugs well your other coping
mechanism was getting into drugs at the
age of 11 yeah I did that too I mean not
even just like alcohol or weed
brown-skinned we're talking about meth
he was a meth head by the time he was 11
yeah I did meth at 11 yeah where do you
even score meth in Poway you can when
you're in frickin no lady named Lucy who
had kids I remember going into her meth
lab and she had date her baby's walking
around this meth lab with it you could
explode at any time and I remember being
12 13 years old you know with like money
i stoled out of my parents safe and
copying that and I was like that's why
in middle school and in high school I
was just like I got all FS
I never got kicked out of school all the
time it was just a weird I was a weird
kid like worried rebellious why of all
drugs did you choose math meth is the
best
should we let our meowing cat in ya get
her in you get her in you're closest to
the door okay she's gonna be out the
whole time if we don't get her
come here memes yeah but um back to that
though it's like the drug it's like even
before that though there was always
something wrong with my brother and I
and I think it's genetics too because
what my grandmother on my dad's mom riot
was paralyzed from the neck down because
she would had a stroke also and she
never left the house if they had this
little house in Korea for like 15 years
she never even saw the daylight really
she didn't want to she just sat in a
room how old was she when she had a
stroke yeah and so when my brother and I
I was maybe nine my brother was six or
whatever my dad found us taking sticks
and whacking against her body
the lady with a stroke yeah my
grandmother oh my god well at first she
would just find a welt all of her body
and he's like I don't know why she
didn't say well I don't know why you
know I mean and then three days later
apparently my brother either side of her
just taking sticks just whacking her
because she was paralyzed
she didn't feel it she just smiled when
we did it she I guess she liked the
attention but like and who does that at
the age of nine that's like serial
killer behavior Jesus Bobby yeah my
brother and I used to do that we did a
lot of stuff like that you know like why
I remember my aunt died when I was maybe
did you beat her to death no we didn't I
beat her to death but I remember like my
brother farted at the funeral and him
and I had to be escorted out because
we're laughing so hard in the funeral
like we had no you know and then my
cousin Andy and I were not allowed to go
back to the church because they found
Andy and I taking gasoline and we were
spreading it in the kitchen
of the church to catch it on fire so we
got kwa arsons know we were all kinds of
things but is that genetic or am I just
evil or was I just confused no like
there is a study that shows like there
is a link like there is such a thing as
like a murderous gene but it's also a
lot of your upbringing so it's like you
could be predisposed to aggressive
behavior it could be predisposed to
addiction but like your your upbringing
can either heighten it or it can dampen
it and in your case because your parents
you know you visibly saw your mom get
beat and your dad was abusive it
heightened all your predispositions to
aggression so it's like there is a
genetic variable to it but you know
obviously it's do you nurture do you
nurture that trait or do you provide you
know a life for a child that's positive
abuse free then yeah you if you do that
you're less likely to look for Lucy and
find meth yeah yeah tonight I was at the
Comedy Store
and I was talking to Steve Byrne who's
comedian we're talking in an office an
Ali Wong walked up Ali Wong is also a
comedian and she's pregnant and she's
visibly pregnant now she's 6 months and
so Steve was like congratulations and
you know I you know I lit up a cigarette
for some reason and then she kind of
backed away that's fine and then then
they asked me go when are you gonna have
kids and I'm like demon spawns yeah I am
too and it's you and me put together
yeah I don't know we're just full of
demon seeds I think yeah I think your
sperm is demon and my egg is demon yeah
well you will that would that
combination maybe maybe she'll do great
job even angel my fear is is that
because I don't you know I've been sober
for thirteen years and it because of my
stints in 12-step programs is the reason
why I'm as nice
or as you know grounded as I am because
without that I'm a maniac but because of
this I can sit here and you know and pay
mortgage and pay my taxes and all the
things but but if we did have children
it would be a great opportunity for you
to break the cycle of your family Oh
having like just an abusive like a long
line of like abusers in your family
because I think that we would provide
that child yeah but you talked to my mom
don't beat my ass yeah but my mom right
is like the day you're born you always
cry you don't stop crying like you know
baby's born like addicted so it's like
to be no moms on like heroin my mom my
mom in 1971 I don't know what people did
in the 70 will crack then your mom is
still married to the guy who knocked her
entire front row teeth out one tooth she
said more okay but I just see one tooth
she has a yeah but anyways I mean this
podcast is turning pretty serious and uh
and real let's make it happier
why now if we don't have to make happy
yeah but you know what the key is this
is that you know if we do have kids I'm
just gonna have to deal with it and and
and just live in the moment and just do
what I can you know but like I just have
this weird fear that it's gonna come
back at me I have concerns yeah I have
concern I'm gonna look at on the scalp
and it's gonna be I'm gonna see a six
and another six another six I got oh my
god it's Damien Damien
you never saw almond oh that kid what
oh no I'm thinking about another movie
the wiggly Imelda Toro one what's I've
never seen omen The Omen is up you
nervous you know I've never seen you
have to see the omen the original one
okay it's so it's really scary and it's
basically this
I don't know its name but I'm a
millionaire you know mewn has a kid but
the kid is Satan
Dameon it was the same son yeah and the
kid it has 666 on his head and it's a
really creepy movie and I'm afraid that
I'm gonna spawn can can we pause real
quick so that kid Damon with a 6 6 6 and
I said 6 6 6 for 6 is 36 sweetie it
concerns me that you haven't seen the
almond this is my problem with you Bobby
you're so like righteous every time I
haven't seen I think if I haven't seen
every single we watched she's never seen
taxi driver so that we I know we watched
it and she's no no she said racist super
racist and then did you not agree
in retrospect yes it's racist but it's
also you have to at the time 1971 or
whatever the movie was made it was a you
know it was a cultural phenomenon super
and it was very real and but it was very
real I loved it I loved the the the
music and I can't get it out of my head
now yeah and then she hasn't seen a lot
of things look I haven't seen
made-for-tv movies I haven't seen a lot
of like the movies or like shows that
were only ran in America cuz I didn't
come here until I was 15 so I wasn't I
didn't know a lot of you know American
pop culture that's true I'm so sorry
because I mean imagine like now if if we
raise the child in the Philippines the
world is flat because of the Internet
right so it's like yeah they have access
to basically everything as long as you
have the Internet
but when I was growing up I would the
only American thing that we would have
would be like we had this thing called
song hits and you and the side of the
road like in in in Cebu they would sell
these little notebooks of song lyrics
right because people would just you know
they would have the song lyrics and then
the the chords to play it because
everyone plays guitar back home because
a huge guitar factories and everything
so basically I'm the only one that
doesn't play the guitar in the
Philippines but that's what you would do
in your free time you would just buy
song hits little note book and you would
memorize lyrics so I may not know a lot
of movies and all these shows that you
make reference to but I know everything
lirik of every american [ __ ] song
that's ever been made okay so I mean I
make up for it in some areas is all I'm
saying so cut me some slack if I didn't
see taxi driver until like two weeks ago
smells like teen spirit
no I don't I can't sing oh my god that's
so funny
hmm that's funny I was actually just
thinking when I was thinking of song
hits I was thinking of Nirvana yeah but
I was thinking of all apologies when I
was telling you that story because
there's this there's this lion in all
apologies that I thought that maybe the
Filipinos got it wrong and in their
little song hits notebook because it
says aqua seafoam shame and I was like
awesome Filipino made that [ __ ] up like
that's not that's actually not what the
lyrics are so I cross-referenced two
days ago and to see if they made you
know they made it up and that's what the
lyrics are aqua seafoam shame really
yeah could I tell you another thing yeah
in the late sixties when my mom was
coming to America the Beatles were
banging and she thought that let it be
was meta G which means Medici which
means anchovy right and I told my mom I
go there's no [ __ ] way and that John
Lennon would write a song about
anchovies number one and also would use
Korean language to do it but do you know
what Asians do what in the Philippines
it's very much okay to take a song and
then change up the lyrics to make it
either Korean or like Filipino yeah and
then they'll re-release it that way like
you know Radiohead creep illegal no it's
illegal right but they would play this
[ __ ] on the radio yeah so in less
Princeton that song creep by Radiohead
you know that that line goes you know so
[ __ ] special that one yeah in the
Philippines they changed it to show
bound and special which means like a
special show power which is like a pork
bun yeah any it's just what you do and
people think it's that's their form of
comedy and people love it yeah so it's
like that maroon 5 song you know yeah
she does she will be loved that phrase
they changed it to see you win
blood which means like it's like a weepy
vagina or like a little like sad vagina
oh it's it's I don't know why Filipinos
do that but they just do so I'm not
surprised I'm not surprised that your
mom you know she thought that Phantom
Menace was a good movie it was the
second movie I ever watched American
theaters it's one of the worst movies in
Rome and because of the anticipation
behind it but and it just delivered I
wasn't the only one because I remember
people cheering after the movie in retro
you know what you did to Bobby the only
reason you don't you admitted to me yes
the few days ago that you actually
thought it was pretty good until you
watched it again like ten years later so
you're at fault too
oh let me say okay hold on all right
maybe you're right maybe you're wrong
okay but I'm gonna ask brown-skinned did
you think it was good when you first saw
it exactly because we were raised with
the first three and it's a part of our
it's a part of you in your heart and so
when you use the same sound effects and
the opening music and it kind of
resembles the first three you were
tricked on believing that it was good
but then when you just once the smoke
the clout wouldn't call that the smoke
clears and you could get to see it again
it's really bad well he was telling me
well first brown-skinned have you seen
the interview of the kid that plays
Anakin Skywalker have you seen his
interview now he's a dick he's an
unhappy guy who who just like does not
which is weird because he was like I
don't want to answer any questions like
involving you know he's in his 20s or
something like that but he doesn't want
to answer questions yet he's in a
convention he's at like a sci-fi
convention he doesn't want to answer
questions about Star Wars at all it's on
YouTube you have to watch it oh that's
my past dude and it's like I don't even
think about it
it's like [ __ ] you had a
convention yeah yeah one of the worst
performances I've ever seen I didn't
notice that when I watched him and I
looked into the camera at one point he's
a baby
it doesn't matter look at Haley Joe
[ __ ] genius
that kid cries on cue he's very real you
know what are you looking at me like
that for nothing I was thinking of Haley
Joel Osment oh how bad he looks she
thinks that Haley Joel Osment looks like
Harold horrible now I just think I don't
think god it's so awful but it's right
it's true I just think that he looks
I was wrong though cuz the other day I
was like I think that he's like on
castable like you can't possibly cast
him in anything now and he has a show on
Netflix where I think he plays like a
teacher and it's like a pretty big show
he's the lead so I'm like okay I put my
foot in my mouth I know nothing he's
super talented he's talented you're
never gonna take that away from him
that's true all right and in Hollywood
it shouldn't be about looks I know it is
they should be about the talent nobody
know but he's just so recognizably Haley
Joel Osment but in a weird body now what
cause he says yeah it's yeah it's like
it's okay to not be a trap blows bread I
like who cares he's into carbs I mean I
can't you know I don't hate him for that
I think it's cool when like like though
there's no Dakota Fanning she hasn't
been anything in a while right but she's
she's pretty girl I know but when she
comes back like and it's gonna be a big
thing when she gets older and people are
gonna go she's already done adult roles
cuz she did that one where she played
like Joan dad Joan Jett movie yeah like
Josh Brolin right remember he was in
Goonies do you remember that he was in
Goonies and then you didn't see him for
a very long time and now he's in no
country old for Old Men you're like oh
this guy's killing us ten years ago or
whatever I'm just saying that he
disappeared for a long time yeah I know
you played Bush eww you thought so
that's so bad right now
after I watched just move on after I
watched w yeah I actually started not
George Bush as much
why because Josh Brolin did such a good
job of humanizing him and just making
him making if that was in fact like
accurate it it made him sort of this
like lovable
you know [ __ ] you know country
[ __ ] dude like it made him I
understood it understood his lunacy he
was he wasn't a very smart guy but he
you know he would he had good intentions
that this didn't [ __ ] didn't were on the
show it was Cheney and Rumsfeld and they
ran the show and he just was uh you know
he was overpowered by these two gigantic
like powerhouse but most of that movie
follows his life prior to I just want to
say this too is is that my friend
Charlie tonight had dinner Finn and he
we talked about Bush and we talked about
how we kind of miss him he was a funny
president he was fun to make fun I don't
know he was literally legitimately
hilarious like when heat when the shoe
is thrown at him right and he eyes the
shoe the second shoe he dodges it and he
smirks and that that's a funny thing
when he goes to other countries he
starts dancing it's really funny and he
does he knows he's funny you know he's
just he's just wasn't the best president
but you know I I miss him you know in
many ways I mean you miss seeing moments
like that but you don't miss him going
into another country for weapons of mass
destruction that were I don't miss that
part no no like that's really that's
really a real life and also I don't miss
you know that his supporters really
they can't be worse than like the like
the tea party though they can't be worse
than like the Sarah Palin supporters and
they cannot be worse than Donald Trump
supporters no they just can't be worse
than a fan of his so yeah relatively
speaking George Bush's actually to me
the lesser of two evils at this point I
like Trump know why just something about
like his hair you're just saying that to
antagonize me no no I really like him
you're a [ __ ] idiot Bobby y-you don't
mean that I do name one thing you like
about him other than his [ __ ] hair or
his hair plugs I love that he just says
whatever is on his mom
mind and he doesn't you know he's not a
politician he doesn't edit himself like
a politician you know he says how he
feels and that in many ways is a good
quality really oh you're gonna get so
much you're gonna we're gonna lose all
our Mexican fans over that one comment
retract Bobby retract I'm kidding say
sorry to the Mexican sorry Mexicans
comas downstairs grow so we retract that
comment yeah whatever if I [ __ ] see a
Donald Trump sticker on our fridge yeah
you and I might be over okay never
whoever becomes president has no power
okay lobbyists and big corporations are
in this country and there's nothing
capitalism runs this country and there's
really nothing we can do about it we're
all pawns and we're all you know sheep
and we just follow whatever and we and
and they fool us by putting out these
movies and contraptions or we get
distracted and you know like destiny or
you know but you city or whatever but
being an eternal optimist and us just
complaining about it doesn't make for
and it doesn't make anything better
no so the least you can do is hope that
you know you elect someone into office
that has a little bit of it and who
isn't the [ __ ] racist Bobby inkling
back in their options our offices are I
don't want to talk politics can we
switch [ __ ] topics we're at 50
minutes there sweets
that's what proms don't promise good so
I think that every episode should have
like an MMA minute let's not doing MMA
minute okay tell me why you are enamored
and obsessed with you wanna UJ Jack okay
yeah you wanna yo J jack is um my
favorite fighter I've ever seen in any
fighting sports is that right yeah clear
bobby watches are all her fights against
Carla Esparza Jessica penne all her like
old like Moy
- I fight every night before he goes to
bed he doesn't watch any other [ __ ]
UFC fight obsessed with her obsess every
night but he doesn't watch
Dimitri's job he doesn't care about
anybody else but Johanna
yeah she is what she's mine than when I
follow she's the one that is showing me
the light he doesn't even care about
Ronda Rousey no I [ __ ] I've met her
she's nice lady right I told Joe Rogan
two weeks ago I said is there any way
that you can I can smeet her and he goes
right look why she's a [ __ ] beast
she's a clinical beast and here's what I
like that girl Paige Vanzant you know
she's a pretty girl she's I in the ring
she's I okay but if the thing is is that
fighting should not you know what the
good-looking people you have your other
things that you can do you can model
become an actress sing a song or
whatever you need to do [ __ ]
misogynistic [ __ ] if you're good I think
you think so Bobby things likes her you
know why Bobby likes her because he says
when she cuts weight she looks like a
meth head yeah she looks like a meth
head but she's also very funny I think
she's very funny and I just think that
she's very talented I think that her
strikes are like a man strike she
reminds me of GSP a little bit she's
just very like you know she's very
technically good skilled and I'm sorry
I'm gonna say this when I see Ronda or
anybody else fight they're great and
they have talent they still look like
we've been fighting because they are
women fighting but Johanna Johanna does
not look like that so you'll only
support fighters that box like dudes I
think Rhonda nice but no I think Ronda
Rousey is extremely talented and she is
a gifted person I'm not saying that I
what I'm saying is is that when when the
fight lasts for 20 seconds it's fine and
dandy but when you have someone like
Johanna who picks them apart round by
round methodically and ripping into
their faces
is so fun to watch like Carla Esparza
when she won the title it was just like
yeah the first 40 minute or two you know
Carla's trying to take her down that's
great okay
but once Johanna established her
striking it was obvious who was the
talented person in the ring it was
something about her personality that I
think you're really drawn to and it's
the fact that she lives in like a small
town and Poland
thick accent everything about her she
pulls he's like you know funny little
antics of like giving her opponents
cookies during weigh-ins or like she
gave penny a bracelet a necklace and
penny didn't take it right and which
will probably only mean infuriated and
more and like that's why I penny got
what she got she's got her face split
open my point is is that she's a very
funny girl she's odd-looking
she's a little odd-looking but she is
devastatingly brutal in the ring
octagon striking is great and she's only
getting better and I don't think that
anybody can give her any trouble other
than Claudia goo Delia your trains with
no Vanya who trains with Josie although
I'm nervous about that fight but I she
can get through that fight I feel like
that she's gonna hold on to the belt for
very long I feel like nobody those two
that you know how there's a huge gap
between let's say like Ronda Rousey
Miesha Tate and like the rest of the
pack I think there is such a huge gap
between Claudia Delia and you wanna age
a check and then the rest of the girls
yeah I mean not to say that Carla
Esparza isn't good but you know it's
like if you really like if you watch
that whole season of The Ultimate
Fighter with with Jessica penne and you
know Carlos bars and all those girls in
in that setting they all look great
but then when you put them next to you
wanna it's just a different freaking
level and it's so obvious yeah in fact I
didn't even know about who she was what
she got kilala got UFC fight pass that I
couldn't sleep one night so I was just
on it and it had this who are the
champions I looked down the very last
person was you wanna and I thought I
never heard of her
so I clicked on her a read her bio
whatever and then I saw related video so
I went into that and when I saw
I saw the first two fights against
Claudia one of them and the other one I
forgot her name she's Brazilian Lima I
think is her name is Lima I thought wow
this girl's pretty good but then when I
saw that as far as up any fights
literally you could hear me say in the
room and we'll kalila up I would every
10 seconds I would go oh my god oh my
god oh my god you know I've never done
that in a fight I woke up I was like are
you watching you wanna that's what she
said
I go yeah she makes me go oh my god that
was devastating oh my god I take that
back there is one other girl who I feel
when she gets a little bit older or when
she gets to be Johannes age is gonna be
a force to be reckoned with
her name is a rose namajunas she's um
pat berries uh she's not cuz Rose was 22
when she was on the show so Rose has to
be like 24 now and Johannes what 27 26
ocean so there may be it almost the same
age your rose just looks so much younger
but Rose has just a really good overall
foundation of everything and she's very
very agile so I think that when she you
know I think that she's one of the other
promising straw weights I guess compared
to the rest of the pack and random
Marko's maybe she's good - yeah it's
exciting to see women fighting in the
UFC but you shouldn't knock girls for
being pretty and fighting Bobby I think
it Ronda Rousey's a total babe Rose
namajunas is it's like seeing a pretty
person doing stand-up comedy they're
there right but it's also kind of like
him deep down inside myself I'm like
come on man this is unfair to say that
but daliyah it listen D'Elia is one of
my best friends and he's really not that
good-looking you know he looks like an
ostrich if you look at his features on
his face I've memorized his face I've
known him for a decade right his face
it's kind of weird
he's got weird bags his nose is a little
weird you know he's just tall he's got
wavy Rick Springfield hair and that's
cool women love him Dain at one point
was the guy but if you look at Dan's
face he's got pot
he's not really that good-looking right
there's certain guys that are like
Anthony Jeselnik very handsome looks
very handsome yeah okay I'll give you
Jasmine back who else really has their
know but they're not twenty Thornburg
handsome you know which I've seen you
know Tony Thornburg is brown skin Tony
Thornburg is a Japanese Swedish model
and a male model
Bobby has it's not it's beyond a man
crush it's basically like he would
definitely like give him a good hand job
no no that's that's that's actually the
opposite of what I would do and that's
actually offensive that you would even
say something like that that's it look
at him alright
what I would do with him I wouldn't be
alone with a room with him I feel like
if we had kids we might produce a Tony
Thornburg that'd be great
but I'd be so proud but if I saw a 20th
Orenburg I would shake his hand for a
very long time
for a very long time and I would pull
away very slowly would you give him the
finger tickle on the inside of the palm
yeah and if he said hey I have HIV like
a weird disease and the only way that I
could live is if you sucked my peanuts I
would do it not out of listen I would do
it to save his life I think you would do
it to listen to me brown skin
let me I'm gonna look at me riding a red
brown skin I'm not gay dude but if you
had cancer and the only way that you
could get cured right is for me to suck
your penis you would have to die I think
you would die all right Toria Thornburg
would live yeah yeah you would have to
perpetuate the the good seeds you know
what I mean you have to you would have
to save like his his breed like he's
genetics like you have to preserve it
like he's a perfect specimen we have a
connection to him my friend in the in
Hawaii her name's Nicole and she's a
model an artist and she's done shoots
with him that's the reason why I even
found out who he was and I showed his
picture to Bobby and Bobby got all like
googly eyed brown skin if I had cancer
and I said the doctor says the only way
that I would live is if you suck my
penis would you
yeah yeah but why would it have to be
just him just how much to look at just
yeah I don't know why let's just suppose
it's the scenario you would you know
what exactly you know what you would die
lives well as brown-skinned have to die
how do you know his genes aren't
superior does it matter actually no your
genes aren't superior in Bobby's eyes
because you're a Filipino and therefore
you're a dirty jungle Asian yeah I
didn't say that
he says that every episode of all the
podcasts we've ever done he calls me a
jungle asian and the fact that you have
browner skin than me makes you a dirtier
jungler jungler asian in the next
episode I want to get into jungle Asians
and I want to get into other Asian why
are you easy to rip into my people I
will get into that the next episode the
next episode will be dedicated to
ripping my people I've been in I've
gotten so much trouble for saying it and
I don't mean it in a mean way I don't
mean it in a race racial kind of a way I
mean it as a factual way that that
you're Asian people that live in the
jungle how is that bad but the
Philippines is not all jungle dumb
that's pretty much jungle I've been
there Cebu is a no I know it's a
metropolis built in a jungle no we don't
have we have mountains you don't have
there's no jungle there then most of the
jungles are in Mindanao it's in the
south that's where we have the rubber
trees and that's how we have you know
thicker denser yeah okay Cambodia has
you know a cities so you put us all
under one jungle umbrella yes and we'll
get into the next episode you know
you've gotten [ __ ] from Vietnamese
people from from other but you know
who's never given him [ __ ] for calling
them jungle Asians Filipinos I think
that we're just I don't think that we
get off I don't know do we just take you
know that type of I said that that ideas
once on camera and I had to apologize
for a year I got in so much trouble Joe
Rogan I was on one of Joe Rogan's videos
and I said that I got in trouble twice
though
it's a jungle Asian and the second thing
I talked about a family member I got a
really in trouble for oh yeah yeah we
wanna get in that but um that's another
reason why we couldn't air the first
episode yeah he told them we're not
gonna say this we're gonna say the story
for maybe like the 50th episode or maybe
like an anniversary episode yeah but he
almost opened on our first episode
telling a story that would we would have
never been able to follow it was such a
huge bomb of a story like the the it was
it's explosive it's mind-blowing
what story he was about to drop yeah and
I know this about him but no one in his
entire in this entire world knows it
about him not even his family what was
it again
Steve oh yeah yeah that's it
anyway that was good that was a good
podcast thanks brown-skinned we'll see
you guys next time